Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burns time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
And I
yes,
check it it on Ya.
Oh,
that was a good one.
The lovely near here.
Yeah.
Gimme gimme a microphone here.
I got to pass this through because otherwise the wires are all crossed to,
oh,
I got the wires crossed.
The wires are crossed.
We're sitting here.
Is that better?
Yup.
Me and the lovely Nia we have on the reason he is here is I hit,
we have a huge announcement to make that as of this morning.
Yeah.
Nian and I die.
Yes.
Became to people that yes.
Had corned beef hash for breakfast.
Absolutely.
And we are so proud and we're so happy and we just want to thank everybody for
your support,
your support over the last few months and for your thoughts during this
difficult time maybe isn't here yet.
So I've been,
I become like a sitcom dead just fucking hanging out with the house by big
fucking socks.
Bill's got big fuzzy socks on the thing.
That's right.
You got your colon.
Yeah.
Yeah,
because I get hot.
we have hardwood floors.
It knee is fucking walking around more pregnant than anybody I've ever got DMC.
So it's like she could be standing in Antartica being like,
can we put on the AC?
And I'm over here fucking chilly willy.
So I got on my uh,
pregnant.
I'm just like a human G.
Gettel I am short and stout were all baby.
You're all baby.
You look good to me.
Thank you.
Anyways,
uh,
so we're sitting out here on a rainy fucking Sunday.
It's been raining cats and dogs out here.
And uh,
did they say rainy Sunday?
Did I say Sunday?
I don't know.
It feels like a Sunday.
It's a fucking Thursday.
Whatever.
Pouring outside.
And you know what pissed me off yesterday on the news,
some fucking idiot.
Like they announced out here in California,
they said the drought is over.
Does because it rains well now because it rained so much that this flooding,
but like this shit's going to stop and then this,
this is going to have to last us for like four years.
Cause you know,
the next sheet like,
well how much does it have to rain for it to no longer be a drought?
That's my question.
Well I think just the mere fact that it's raining mean that there's no,
no,
no water levels in all the reservoir was,
I believe,
I'm just would guess that this,
they have to get to a certain level because when I did my bus tour burning my
own hole in the fucking California ozone,
sure.
When,
uh,
we went by all these big reservoirs that were for,
you know,
drinking water or just even people just ride boats around or whatever.
Like you could see the waterline.
I mean it was like to like,
you know,
a brown stone in New York,
picture like two or three of those stacked on top of each other that low and
the,
it looked like it was a half mile across and he was fucking ridiculous.
Yeah.
It was,
it was terrifying to be honest with you.
So evidently it's gotten up to an acceptable level,
so now everyone's going to start taking fucking long showers.
You know what I mean?
Just,
you know what kills me out here?
Every time when it starts to fucking rain and you wash all,
you watch all that water going down the La River,
that goes all the way down to Marina del Rey,
I believe.
And then it just goes out to the ocean.
It's like,
why don't you capture that somehow in save it all that runoff.
Yeah.
I mean,
I think environmentalists would like that to happen.
It's a very complicated class that
kids couldn't have books in schools anymore.
If we captured the raid one and we did that,
then we'd have to cut this.
And I dunno.
It sounds like,
it seems like it's complicated.
Maybe it's not.
I don't know.
Yeah,
you have.
You have no energy today.
Can you hear it in my voice?
You have like rainy day energy.
I have rainy day in pregnant as fuck energy,
rainy day in praying.
It brings me down.
Well,
why don't you just fucking have the kid just fucking,
you know.
Oh,
I wish I could.
I wish we could have it right now.
Yeah.
You know what?
You know what's funny is I've been like joking about this on stage is the level
that people have been trying to,
uh,
every day I get a text it will say,
did the kid come yet?
And I'll say no.
And then the followup Texas,
are you nervous?
It's like,
well I wasn't,
I was sitting here relaxed.
Like they just get you on edge and I'm just like,
it's been this great process where I'm just like,
wow man,
I always listened to people.
I need to stop doing that because it doesn't help you if they just,
I was joking on stage like they were getting your like,
you know when you get a dog all excited,
like you want to go inside,
how do you want to go outside?
Like that's what they're doing to you.
Like he's a baby here and you're nervous and freaking out like three or four
texts a day for like the past three days.
It's like,
no,
baby's not here yet.
You sound like you drank some of that.
What's that?
What's that rank?
You sound like your lien.
Is that what the kids are doing nowadays with the fucking cough syrup and their
Irish spring that they take a cheese grater and they fucking hair spring.
That's one of my favorite things to dirty sprite.
That's what future calls it.
I like when you got all these,
these fucking people on the Internet and they show you how to make it,
cause I was sitting,
it was a comedian.
I got to know what's going on.
Oh,
did you look online to see how it's made?
Yeah,
it's literally sprite and like codene like prescription and they take like a
car.
Someone put a jolly rancher or some shit in there.
But like if you just look at the ingredients on the back of the fucking thing.
Yeah,
yeah.
Like,
uh,
I got to hand it to this generation.
All these generations.
Every time you think like,
you know,
wow.
Like,
like I always say in my generation there was crack babies and I'm just like,
okay,
that's it.
That's the end.
That's as fucked up as you as you're going to see like human beings do things
like,
like as a parent,
I wouldn't be able to be shocked like you're doing what right.
Then came meth heads,
which literally looked like walking dead people.
They're not zombies,
but they're not real people anymore.
They have like fucking Nate.
Like when I would do gigs out in the Midwest,
you know,
ion in further west into those states,
celebrities go to buy a log cabin and buy a fucking pretend they own a grizzly
bear outfit.
Right?
If you go out there and they had like this before and after pictures of people
on meth.
Yeah,
yeah.
And I was just like,
Holy Shit that,
that made,
that blew my fucking mind.
And now looking at these guys,
I mean I guess this isn't as bad as math,
but just watching beans will always find a way to get high though new creative
ways to get high.
That's just kinda how it goes or you think,
but I'm a sound like an old man here.
What,
what was wrong with what the fuck we did?
You can't just drink a couple of beers.
I mean what's that fucking drink that they're drinking?
That's like shit homeless people do or like,
like full on alcoholics and people will not fucking give you like money for
booze anymore and you just don't have it that that's what they used to do.
They go and they start drinking nyquil.
Yeah,
cause the prescription and any of that stuff is really like,
I don't know,
I've never drank that kind of stuff before.
But it's supposed to mimic the feel of opioids.
Opioids,
opioids,
opiates.
You mean?
Oh No opioid it is the correct.
We've got some bump on your ass.
No,
that's a hemorrhoid.
I thought opiates.
So that's opiates.
Opiates.
Hemorrhoids is also a word.
It is,
I think is that when you take like the qtip laced with this shit and you put it
in your ass.
I don't know why you were,
what the ad?
No,
no.
There was a thing that these kids were doing.
There was soaking something.
I swear to God,
I went down a rabbit hole.
How these kids get high.
There was this fucking thing they were doing.
They were taking something acute dip or something and it was so good in this
shit that got you high and then they'd stick it in their ass because there's a
thin membrane there.
Leave it.
Yeah.
Like how people blow coke up each others ass and stuff.
No.
Yeah.
That's the thing.
That is not a thing.
I know.
You know what?
I'll go with the fucking Q tip up the ass.
No,
it totally is a thing.
Hang on a sec.
That is not a fucking thing.
The old coke in the ass.
Yeah.
Just picture what that looks like.
What are you,
your cup it in your hand and then you can go spread it wider.
Wider and yeah,
no fucking way.
Probably use like a straw.
It's a funnel in the Enos.
Really.
And how well do you know this person?
I do.
We've been friends for a while.
Right?
You know I've seen you drink drinks,
you use a strives astrar right.
That's not really crazy.
You know and we both have acids.
So
I got this bag of coke.
Hear me out.
Just hear me out.
Just sit out.
Sit Out.
I'm not taking my pants off.
I was just adjusting my belt.
Let's see.
All right,
coke.
This is going to be on my fucking search at that time.
I go to the apple store.
Coke up.
Yes.
Up the bum
off the arts.
So it's even in England.
I got cocaine blown up my ass.
So you don't have to.
What?
Oh,
that's a vice article.
Of course it is.
Okay.
Wait,
anal use rectal administration.
It's also drugs.
forum.com so
don't put cocaine in your,
but people that said Reddit
a live week.
Dot.
Kang man blows cocaine up a woman's ass.
Yeah.
Was he to numb it before he stuck his fatty in the thing?
So okay.
Wait as well.
You don't encyclopedia dramatica investigate it more.
Just know that it's a thing that exists.
All right,
well then I gotta look mine up.
Well,
I got to read the article here.
All right.
This is what you need.
Some sort of fucking kitchen knife.
Wait,
wait.
Let's not tell people how to do it.
I mean,
I can say,
okay,
this is a real Neil.
When the Internet was suddenly a buzz with rumors that getting a friend to blow
coke up your ass with the straw was worth the trouble I had to see if I'd been
doing it all wrong.
After all,
blow doesn't come with instructions.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
Get to the fucking point.
All right.
I don't know.
There's not gonna be a video.
This is a,
okay.
Okay.
Uh,
I know it's funny.
I said hoping the conversation would cover it,
but I just wanted to understand the possible health effects on a more
fundamental level.
Okay.
So he called somebody physician's viewpoint in a very nice woman named Kate
spoke to me.
I asked her about it and she fell silent.
He said,
I know.
It's funny.
I said,
I was hoping.
She says,
it's more sad actually.
He said,
Oh yeah,
that's the word I should have used.
Said overall.
Kate was extremely helpful and promised to contact all the gastro,
uh,
something,
or I'll just still,
the Internet had spoken.
I had to try it.
That,
that,
that the de this guy.
Okay.
He's,
I'm going to go with the pictures now.
He's got the spoon.
He sticks it in a vile.
All right?
In the end,
my high was no more significant than when I opt for the more orthodox approach.
All right,
so people are doing it because there was the other thing,
the thing I was talking about,
rave,
let me look this up.
Rave drugs.
Yeah.
Ass Search.
Somebody's got their booty eating it and all in an American festival.
Strange happenings regarding Edm festivals,
raves and drugs.
Okay.
Strange happenings regarding Edm festival raves and drugs them.
Dot.
Thought them and going to eat their ass.
Not really.
And not what people are thinking.
How to smuggle in gear to a concert.
Jesus Christ shaking her ass at a rave party.
Wicked woman.
I don't know why I get it right.
We can't move off this topic.
This is getting weird.
Let me just get weird.
We're not doing it.
We're just researching Townsend.
Hey,
the San Diego,
uh,
moving up to Los Angeles.
Oh,
is saw something online about that.
Yeah.
They finally,
they're returning home where they belong.
They were the Los Angeles chargers for one season.
The first year,
the AFL,
they're back where they started.
Here they come round again.
Hey,
wait it nia go.
It's almost like she's having a contraction
dude.
You got to ask yourself as a San Diego charger fan after all the fucking
heartache and everything,
he just went through and now they're going to fucking walk out on you.
You know,
you gotta be asking yourself like,
what,
what was that off?
What was that all for?
You know,
great.
I actually am back as much as they hated as much as they hated the fucking,
the Patriots and Tom Brady and I had a horrible fan experience when I went down
there and were patriots tests not real and how much realizing how much they
hated us.
Um,
I just don't know.
I just,
I actually felt bad for them as fans because it wasn't that they lost,
it's the way they lost.
They did the old Boston red sox thing.
What we used to do before we started winning all the championships was we
couldn't just have the decency to just suck like the cubs all those years.
You don't have,
the cubs just sucked.
They had like two errors too to Eric Games,
one of the early eighties and then they had the fucking one where they blame
that,
that fucking a little nerd,
you know,
rather than the other six people that stood up around them also trying to catch
the ball.
They had to,
to heartbreakers.
That was it.
Other than that,
it was a big keg party.
Everybody standing there with their shirts off.
They all live in Wrigleyville.
They got money.
They're not sympathetic people,
you know what I mean?
Um,
but charge offense,
you know what I mean?
They just like a,
they had that fucking old ass God damn stadium.
They wrote it out.
They were down there.
They came close in like 95 got their fucking asses kicked was at 95 and 94 when
Steve Young got the monkey take it off his back.
Wasn't that what it was near?
Ah,
yeah.
Steve Young who claimed the Patriots should have all of their championships
taken away because a spy gate,
one of the dumbest things I ever heard,
it's like,
yeah,
that's Great Steve.
It's a brand new rule.
It was illegal for one game.
So when it wasn't illegal because we were doing it back then,
then they should get charged for it when the rest of the league was also doing
it.
Alright,
whatever.
So welcome to La.
We went from no football teams to Tunia.
Now,
how does that make you feel?
Are you excited?
No.
Yes.
Would say no.
I don't care.
I'm kind of um,
you know,
I need to tap out and different.
You're done now.
I'm okay.
You're okay.
You don't have to go your birthday.
You don't look like you're okay.
I can make it.
Ooh.
It's a good distraction.
All right,
for sure.
For all the guys out there and for the ladies who'd never been pregnant,
what does that feel like at this point?
If you guys are wondering why I'm so fucking relaxed,
she's had so many of these goddamn things.
It's like somebody crying wolf crying wolf.
Yeah.
Now these are,
you know,
you should do to freak me out when I'm there.
Just throw a glass of water on the floor and just be like,
oh,
just watch me
car.
Someone had suggested that I do that to you on Twitter,
but I don't,
I'm not original.
I don't think that's a good idea.
Um,
yeah,
no.
These are called Braxton Hicks contractions.
They are getting you ready for actual real contractions and I've been having
them more and more frequently.
Just answered the question as I'm getting close answer what question?
Like what does it feel like?
Oh,
it feels like an extreme tightening in your abdomen.
No,
relate it to a pain you've had before.
Getting slugged in the shoulder and that's never happened to be having your big
brother grabbed you by one of your ankles and drag it back down the stairs.
Never happened to me.
And this is the only way I can relate to,
it's like just in the ear.
It's like he,
it's like someone is in your stomach,
stretching it out as tight as it can go.
And then it slowly goes back to normal.
Running into the living room cause you missed a big play looking at the TV and
running full speed into the coffee table.
Stomach first.
Sure.
The stomach first.
Okay,
there we go.
I did that.
Yes,
I did that on Monday when I watched,
when I watched uh,
the Alabama Clemson game.
And I know Neil is once you don't like football.
I know you heard me screaming when Clemson scored that last.
You were definitely screaming.
I would be the worst announcer ever.
You don't like the great answers have to be like,
do you believe in miracles?
Yes.
Or like he did it.
He did it.
Flutie did it.
They have like something,
you know the shot heard round the world.
What are the fuck it was the giants win the pennant.
The job I just went like,
yeah.
You weren't going crazy there.
Yeah,
I saw it as like one of the crimson tide.
Oh me d d.
Um,
I actually,
when I was watching that fucking that game I was uh,
I was actually happy for either team winning cause my,
my,
my hatred of Alabama is completely phony.
I'm not from down south.
You know,
I just picked Lsu because I thought that last miles was a gap,
though I thought he was crazy eating grass and shit,
you know,
going forward on fucking field goals,
having the field goal kick of run down the fucking street and slippers scored
touchdowns.
I was like,
Hey,
I'll fucking go with these guys.
You know?
So it just became fun to root against them.
But it was also,
I'm a big fan of history,
Nia.
And,
uh,
he would have tied Paul Bear Bryant if he won another championship.
And I'm also,
La head was saying that Alabama is overrated because yes,
he see was weak and then out.
So then I was kind of rooting for Alabama to beat a team that just fucking beat
the shit out of the Ohio state buckeyes 31 to nothing.
Um,
I was kind of hoping for that.
But then also you've got to get a root for Clemson.
They're the underdog,
right?
It's phenomenal.
This is how much of a Cleveland Guy,
okay.
Jason Law hit is what I love,
Jason.
Okay.
But he has the disease of being a Cleveland Sports Fan when fucking,
uh,
Clemson went up because what happened was Clemson scored,
it looked like they were going to win the game and an Alabama went right down
the field and gave him the old right there,
Fred.
And then Clemson came back when it looked like there was really no time left.
And then they scored and then they want,
right?
So when Clemson went up and it looked like Alabama wasn't gonna have enough time
to score,
Jason texts me about their head coach saying,
he'll find a way to fuck this up.
And I just wrote back,
Jesus Christ,
Jason,
can you just believe?
And then sure enough,
Alabama goes down and scores a touchdown.
And then Jason writes to me,
you Clemson,
you'll lose some almost trying to look like you win some,
you lose some or something like that.
And then Clemson goes down against all of his fucking negative vibes.
They go ahead,
they score the winning touchdown.
You know what he says to me?
He goes out of they should have won it last year.
Want to last year two,
they finally won a championship.
That's what he says.
Um,
I don't know.
Classic Cleveland Guy.
Anyways,
near uh,
we're going to go see a double feature today,
Huh?
Yes.
You're taking me to a,
what am I going to go?
See?
We're going to go see moon.
Are you having another one?
Yes.
All right.
It's the five one.
One rule.
So that's two within five minutes.
I know,
but this isn't a real contraction.
This is just the way you never had a baby.
Did you guys do at the end of this fucking thing?
I've always said he heard a baby crying.
What the fuck?
Because I know this is,
they say,
you know,
you know when the contraction is real and it's like you got to know when to hold
them.
I don't think I'd be able to
hang out and hold a microphone.
The hair.
The kid.
Yeah.
No wind to podcast.
You nailed.
But cow Joe babies sitting on.
So they'll be time for cotton when the Braxton Hicks is done.
Right,
exactly.
We're going to go see moonlight and they weren't going to see hidden figures.
And this is all dependent.
I mean hopefully,
yes,
I won't be moonlight and hidden figures.
My water won't be breaking during any of these.
I was just,
is this make bill woke day
trimester guy?
So I got to just agree with everything that she fucking said.
So I got to go see that.
Then I got to go see hidden figures where you know they're going to do a total
overcorrection of fucking history and they're gonna have a bunch of guys running
around.
Like why wait?
It's supposed to be a really good movie and I'm excited to see it.
I know.
And it's,
it's keyword based on a true story.
Carson,
isn't it?
Kevin fucking Cosla and my girl Jenelle Manya who I love so much.
Remember when went to see her in concert?
We saw before she was famous,
famous,
famous.
We saw when she was just famous,
she was jumping around on the saddle shoes and when she was opening for
somebody,
not all,
she closed.
No,
she opened for Jamie Lidell at the Avalon.
Don't you remember?
I had seen her in a magazine and I was like,
who is this?
And I listened to some of her music and I'm like,
that's cool.
And then do do the week of our wedding,
she was playing at the House of Blues and I went to go see her a couple of days
before our wedding and it was awesome.
And what was my maid of honor?
They took a picture together and we ended up hanging out with her.
And what did you man
afterwards?
What?
What did you have to eat afterwards?
What are you saying?
You just getting to into a lot of detail here.
Oh well excuse me.
Sorry.
I got cabin fever.
Nia.
I said yesterday,
man,
we watch it.
We watched,
I sat in the fucking laid in bed with you.
Yes.
And we watched all those fucking game shows.
Yeah.
We watch jeopardy.
Wait for,
for one.
Oh first we watched the news.
We've turned into a real old couple.
We watched the news and then we went on to Trump yelling at that guy and CNN
fake news.
Fake News.
I won't answer that.
Let her talk.
Don't be rude.
Jeopardy.
And then we watched a wheel of fortune.
Wheel of fortune got boring.
They got rid of all their fucking,
they used to have the worst fucking prize as you had to pick from right in the
end,
they'd be,
it was always like for a $600,
I'll uh,
I'll take the brass bed frame.
Uh,
for five 60,
I'll take the grandfather clock.
I saw like old people shit.
300 bucks.
I'll take the estate jewelry.
Oh my God,
Dad,
father clocks.
I'll take,
put the rest on a gift certificate.
How many people went bankrupt?
Every other fucking spin.
Yeah,
that nerdy black kid.
Every time you would get ahead,
Calvin,
every time.
we'll get ahead
and he didn't win in the end.
I was so sad.
I mean he won,
but then he didn't get the final puzzle.
I think all the Calvins world,
we're winners that day.
All right,
patch.
Say Jack is 70 years old.
Alex Tra Beck is 76.
Alex Trebeck is under contract for another two years.
This is,
this is why my fucking add reacts when I watch the game show.
Cause after a while I can't watch those people excitedly yelling out letters.
Say the lacy,
you'll see there is two C's.
You want to solve a puzzle or could they do spinning?
I'm going to get 10 new Spain,
three 50
is there an l?
Ooh,
I'm sorry.
There's no l Calvin spin the wheel
fucking drove me insane and I can't even,
I never know what it says.
You can have everything but the vowels of still go cat
kitchen titty.
I can never understand.
I never know what the fuck it is.
You're really good in sports.
Jeopardy.
We watch some sports jeopardy this week.
We've been watching a lot of game shows.
That's true.
Oh my God.
Was Killing at sports jeopardy.
The shit that doesn't matter in life.
I know everything about
speaking of which,
how about those Celtics?
Huh?
Sally had a tough one against the fucking raptors of the huskies.
Whatever the fuck they were doing.
Everybody's doing their throwback fucking jerseys.
Um,
Jesus Christ.
I don't know one person's name on the Toronto Raptors,
but I do know DeRozen now.
Holy Shit.
That guy just,
he hit her.
I thought he kept saying the Rosa and of course I just kept thinking of Joe,
Joe,
Joe Rosa of this kind of thing.
He showed her rosa killed him.
He killed us on the raptors.
There's the Photoshop right there.
I want to see Jodie Rosa.
We,
if you can find a fucking picture of him where he kind of looks confident,
you know Joey put up,
put them in with that Toronto huskies fucking throwback,
that guy to rose and killed this man.
Finally,
when he scored like his 41st point,
I think he turned around and looked at our bench or at the crowd and it was,
I didn't even make me upset.
It's just like,
yeah,
dude,
the,
you couldn't,
you couldn't cover the guy.
We had a,
we fucking had them.
Toronto was exactly what we thought they were,
but that's a,
that's that's,
you know,
that's where we're at.
We,
we fight,
we fucking beat everybody else except for the people we're going to run into in
the late rounds of the playoffs.
So,
uh,
it's looking like the Celtics win around or maybe too,
who knows?
Depending on,
uh,
but you know,
that was to become the second seat in the east,
which would have been sweet,
right?
Because this number two place 70,
you know this,
did you just fall asleep?
No,
no,
no.
I feel you want to listen to me read out loud.
Bruins got the prejudice.
We beat the blues the other day.
Put me to sleep.
You know what?
What about when I'm watching your fucking you stupid reality shows it.
Huh?
I actually enjoy them.
Right?
I'm not fucking angry anymore,
Nia.
I try.
I'm trying to keep the anger going.
I don't have it anymore.
Walking,
meditating everyday.
You know what's funny though is me being less angry.
It's like freaking you out.
It's not freaking me out.
I literally gave you prompts all yesterday when we,
after the doctor's appointment and we sat there and we had a nice brunch and I
told you how proud of
and used to it used to unnerve me a little bit when you were calm because I just
thought nothing was wrong with you.
Okay,
look,
I was plotting,
doing something to you.
Oh my God.
Our old friends here,
Indo Chino Indochino is one of the largest to measure men's wear brands and
nothing says I'm happy in my relationship.
Like getting some men's wear.
Get a high quality suit made to your exact measurements.
That's the fucking Shit,
man.
When he got a job where you got to wear a suit,
you come home like who?
Beaumont.
The beginning of the,
leave it to beaver.
Bespoke means for a perfect fit.
Uh,
what's a spoke bespoke?
What does bespoke,
isn't that a suit that's made just for you?
Like all of Conor Mcgregor's suits all that guys get some nice suits.
Hey Dell.
I'll tell you that guy at the only thing nicer than the way knock she had is the
focus suits he wears.
All right.
You will dress like Conor Mcgregor one day.
I'm going to make it happen.
Yeah,
and then you'll see exactly how many pounds I need to lose.
The thing about Conor McGregor is he's in fucking fucking championship shape.
Okay?
I'm in pull,
Lucas shape,
sweatpants and a hoodie.
All right?
You get to,
you get to customize your suit just the way you want it.
Here's how it works.
Visit a show room,
our shop
online at [inaudible] dot com
pick from hundreds of fabrics.
Choose your custom customization from lapels to pleats to jacket linings and
moral.
That's pretty cool.
You can make a fucking really loud suit or something classy.
Submit your body measurements,
place you all.
Don't do that.
Don't submit your fucking measurements over the over the Internet.
Don't ever do it.
Do you think online banking spad you submit your body measurements over the
Internet.
The fucking Illuminati starts making a robot to your exact specifications and
all of a sudden you know everybody notices that you're acting weird.
You know you're kind of you,
but you're not you.
That's because the robot showed up one day and you were like,
hey me,
what are you doing here?
And then it gives you the Oh right there,
Fred over your fucking,
you know,
chokes you out with your tie that you got from Indochina.
All right.
Submit your body measurements,
place your order and wait for it to arrive in just four weeks.
This week.
My lesson is,
can get any Primo Indochino suit for just 389 dollars@indochino.com when
entering burr at checkout,
that's 50% off the regular place price for a man made to measure premium suit
plus the shipping is free.
That's indochino.com Chino promocode birth for any premium suit for just $389
and free shipping.
Uh,
it's I,
It's like China with an o.
It's like out sting would say China.
I went to um,
incredible deal for a suit that will fit you better than anything off the rack
ever could.
All right.
Oh,
here we go.
Blue Apron,
everybody.
Oh,
blue ball apron,
blue apron.
You know,
not all ingredients are created equal.
No.
Jesus who wrote this?
That fucking guy Trump just appointed to a attorney general.
You know,
not all ingredients are created equal.
Some of them,
God likes better.
You know,
they're just smarter.
You know that got better hair.
Oh they,
they,
they sunburn a little bit more of my,
maybe they can't ban.
Okay,
I'll give you that.
Maybe they're better.
Do with Oh,
set shot the jump shot.
All right.
Fresh high quality ingredients make a real difference.
So important to know.
So it's important to know where your food comes from.
Talking about your personal experience with Blue Apron.
Oh Jesus.
You know,
I always wore white aprons and I put on a blue one and you know,
I felt I felt a little cooler affordable for less than $10 per person.
Per meal.
Blue Apron delivers seasonal recipes along with proportion to Greens to make
delicious home cooked meals.
I have to tell you this guys,
if you want to fucking lose weight,
if you're working out,
the biggest God damn thing,
especially become old like me,
is what the fuck you put into your body.
So one of the big pains in the ass,
it's going to the Goddamn grocery store.
Wouldn't it be wonderful if somebody just brought the shit to your fucking door
all measured out and you can just throw it together after you work out?
Wouldn't that be fucking perfect?
Wash the pounds,
go away.
Suddenly,
you know,
all of a sudden it's like you're going around the world looking over.
All of a sudden you can finally see the head of your Dick again.
You know,
Oh my God,
you're like Christopher Columbus,
okay.
And you and you and your junk is the fucking West indies.
Um,
do we really have to read all of this?
It's their fucking incredible meals.
Okay.
Check out this week's menu and get your first three meals for free with free
shipping by going to blue apron.com/ [inaudible] you will love how good it feels
and tastes to create incredible home cooked meals with blue apron.
So don't wait.
That's blue apron.com/burr blue apron.
A better way to cook,
um,
each meal step by step.
You know that shit customized recipes.
They got varieties,
they got a different fucking recipe every God damn day.
All right,
lift everybody.
L Y,
F,
T.
Lifed.
You know about Lyft,
right?
This is like when you're in eighth grade,
somebody brings up something,
you know,
something about sex.
You know what that means,
right?
You're like,
yeah.
What does it mean?
Um,
it's the APP that gets you a ride in minutes on demand 24,
seven for less than the cost of a cap.
Please include all of the following points during your read.
Of course,
I will.
Um,
oh,
you're back.
I'm back.
I was worried you went and just had a baby.
Needs a bath if you tried Lyft,
you know what I mean?
With Lyft,
you just download the APP requested driver and they show up in three and a half
minutes on average
fucking sweat and all coked up.
That's really fast.
Every driver delivers.
Every,
every Lyft driver is fully vetted through their 10 point safety standard.
Yeah.
Unlike those other cunts,
once you got ahead and fucking hands and a foot to step on the gas pedal,
you've got a job over there including criminal and DMV background checks.
You know,
you'll get around quickly and safety lift drivers are rated after every ride.
So only the best stick around.
You don't have to worry about getting into a filthy car with some creepy dude
like they do over there.
Um,
I can't say the name of them,
but it rhymes with boober.
Justin boober girl,
you know,
you're the one for me.
Whoa.
That's boy band shit right there.
With Lyft,
you can tip in the APP,
which obviously leads to happier drivers.
Nine out of 10 Lyft riders get a perfect five star rating.
That's because most people are too mean to give a tent and like risk like rex
reed right now are too mean to not give a tip.
Sorry.
Some sort of Gong show shit just fell into my head.
Bigger isn't always better.
People lift isn't the biggest ride sharing app,
but it's the fastest growing in the highest rated one.
I'm talking quality over quantity.
Thanks to lift.
You got an easy way to avoid drunk driving.
You never have to bum a ride and you never have to worry about parking is so
perfect for fucking la.
I'll tell you that right now.
A lot of people are actually getting ry,
getting rid of their drivers,
the cars and and uh,
relying on Lyft to get around.
This is a brutal read.
Sorry.
And you know what?
I don't blame him.
Well,
how the fuck do you know or light blame?
I doubt it's a nice guests lift.
All right.
Right now,
Lyft is offering our listeners a special deal.
Get three free rides,
up to $10 each.
That's up to $30 value when you enter a promo code or just download the free
Lyft app today and went,
wait,
that's confusing.
Lyft is offering our listeners a specialty to get three free rides up to $10
each aisle.
So they take you around the block.
We all right,
we want to go to the store that's gonna cost you money.
All right?
Uh,
where am I?
Promo Code Burr Bill Burr,
enter Promo Code Bill Barr at their website.
Whatever the fuck it was that I said and I was that,
was that a good read?
How come they don't have,
they don't have their website in their,
do they do you know I had an idea the other day.
Nia,
can you believe that I had an idea.
You,
you um,
I want to buy like a 1948
like Cadillac limousine.
Okay.
I have the,
just whenever they fucking have the interior looked nice,
however,
the outside of the car,
whatever.
Okay.
Then you get the powertrain,
the Sh air shocks all and shit.
Gas Monkey,
the whole fucking thing up.
Right.
And then I get a fucking,
I get a driver,
right?
So I never have to deal with la traffic again.
I just jumped in the back.
I got a little fucking bar,
I've got a little humor,
doors,
some cigars,
and then I got a little Wifi so I can get hammered.
Smokers cigar to some business calls.
And then anytime there's ran around the city all day,
no,
anytime I want to go out,
you cause out here.
The big thing with La is there's no place to park.
Like you'll pull into a strip mall that has like 10 fucking businesses and they
have like 15 parking spots.
Right.
And they tell the employees not to park there,
but you know they're going to park there and there's never any place to park.
Sure.
If this guy just pulled up whap way parkway it and I just got out,
then he fucking drove away.
How much things would cost to have to have a driver?
Does the driver Hong Kong have a fucking driver?
Like I mean just sits down the street like a creek.
Read the fucking newspaper.
I think there's a lot of holes in this fucking thing.
A few hundred bucks a day for sure.
Bullshit.
Nobody's going to sit here for fucking 24 hours for 200 bucks.
Yeah,
they would call her ass.
The other word,
you can definitely hire a private driver that's just on call for you.
You say,
Hey,
can you get here at 10 or whatever.
I got to go here,
here and here and just hang out until I need you again.
If you pay somebody enough,
they'll do it.
Why wouldn't I?
You know what?
As I liked driving too much,
but there's those times like whenever you go into a fucking game and all that,
I'm basically describing having my own lift,
you know?
Yeah.
Cause I don't like it cause now it's just one person who knows where I live.
Whereas those other people,
they know where everybody knows where you fucking live and then they fucking
track you.
Yeah.
It's like we just did Uber.
Does Uber know those guys do that all the fucking time?
They start tracking it.
Then they listened.
They hack into your phone.
They start listening to you.
You can corned beef hash looking at your raved drugs ass search.
Yeah.
Watching somebody take a straw,
blow cocaine up your ass as you're going like,
hey,
you know,
I don't feel any higher than us.
I guess it was really no reason to do that.
Let's just do it.
There are nasal passages like we did before.
That's like something jackass.
What had done back in the day and they would all be laughing the fucking asses
off.
That was the part of the movies I could never share.
They've done it.
I could never like those parts of the movie where there was,
there was always those parts where they would just do something like a pubic
hair sandwich or put that little toy car up his ass.
You think Steve own never had coke blown up his ass.
I mean,
I'm sure if that was this thing for like two weeks now.
I don't think he did that.
He's a very conventional person.
Okay.
Man,
when he steps away from the camera,
he's very conservative.
Right?
I've done stand up with them a couple of times.
He fucking great guy.
He said that.
He said he's like a really nice person.
Yeah.
With an,
with an incredible fucking like sense of humor,
right.
Really,
really funny.
Fucking guy.
Um,
all right,
legal zoom.
This is the last one.
Everybody.
Legal Zoom.
Start of a new year's perfect opportunity to hit the reset button for a fresh
start to finally get around to things you've been putting off for too long and
legal zoom.com is where you make it happen.
So when they take control of your family's future,
whether it's state land,
I'd finally get your dream business up and running.
Don't let legal questions hold you back.
Sorry.
It just seems like it's always such dry coffee with these people.
It seems you don't even let that black dude who does the,
uh,
was it all state?
Dennis Haysburt.
Yeah.
Are you in good hands?
He's Jewish.
I didn't know that.
They see was he,
is He Sammy Davis Jr son?
Cause I know he converted.
His last name is Haysburt.
Oh he said he's Berg and Hayes boy.
No.
All right.
The legal world can be challenging to navigate.
That's why legal zoom was created over 15 years ago.
To provide you with the tools you need,
the confidence you already have and the know how to wrap up your legal needs.
And since legal zoom isn't a law firm,
you know I have to worry about expensive hourly fees.
Instead,
you can get legal advice at flat rates from the network,
from the networks of attorneys in 48 states.
They'll help you with the right estate plan or answer the questions you have for
running your business.
Call to action,
make 2017 the year you get your life in order and get special savings when you
enter Promo Code [inaudible] at checkout legal zoom.com.
There you go.
All right,
let's end.
And let's talk about a Meryl Streep's Golden Globe speech.
What did you think about that and IA?
Did you think it was historically accurate?
Was it something that data debate sad?
There was something that I wasn't surprised that she said
she's been a,
you know this,
she does this.
I wasn't mad in it and in,
I mean the only thing I took offense to,
I wasn't mad.
Aside from the usual thing of like,
oh good.
Someone who pretends to be somebody else going to tell us how the world needs to
be run.
All right.
You thought it was a little,
what's word fame?
What's your new word that you learned?
Oh,
sanctimonious.
He thought it was a little thing to ammonious.
I really don't know what that means.
Cool.
Little holier than now.
I just did.
Oh,
those are always just cringe worthy moments when everyone from a Margaret Moore
who,
whatever his fucking name is,
Michael Moore,
Margaret and Meryl Streep and all these people are got to be like,
guys,
you know,
we're living in a really dangerous time right now.
I just really think it's really important for us all to hold each other and your
loved ones a little bit closer.
Just that it's filler.
It's fucking filler.
It's just filler.
I just don't,
I,
I don't,
I don't fucking buy it.
And then in the end you fucking attack bread and circus,
you know,
football and MMA.
Yeah.
Like we're all a bunch of movies and I like MMA.
How come?
They have to be separate?
But the majority of her message I thought mean was feeling yourself is an art
form.
Defending yourself as an art form from Dominica.
Doing martial arts always picked the Oregon could do.
Um,
yeah.
Well like I said,
this is,
you know,
Merrill and are there actors like her,
they'd have a platform and they feel passionate about it and so they speak on
it.
You give me one instance,
anything wrong with that?
Give me one fucking cause and I'll give you the speech right now off the top of
my head with every fucking cliche and I would be called brave if anybody gave a
fuck about me.
God,
give me a topic.
Well,
what are you care about?
No,
that's not the point.
The point is giving me something.
I don't even know anything about it.
I could still give the speech.
Oh,
I'm saving the whales.
You know,
when you look at the earth from space,
which so few of us get the chance to do like I did in this movie when I
pretended to be an astronaut,
most of it is water.
And the biggest thing in the water are whales
and like us,
they also communicate.
And just because we don't understand that,
let me finish.
Just because don't understand them does not mean that they are not saying
something and they do not deserve a voice that needs to be heard.
And despite the current administration,
I,
Bobby,
continue fighting for these whales.
Thank you.
Sorry,
I kind of petered out,
but you don't want to be,
I still fucking did it.
I still did it.
And then maybe the next day be like,
it was so brave.
I loved his Cumberbun.
You know,
he was glowing.
He thanked his wife,
be thanked the whales,
he took his shiny thing and then he fucking,
you know,
I dunno.
Took a fucking stretch SUV burning low lead fucking gas into the fucking sunset,
right?
Yeah.
I just don't,
I,
I don't,
I don't give a flying fuck.
I don't need a fucking lecture from an actor on what's going on.
I didn't feel like a lecture.
It just felt like she was passionately talking about something that she felt
strongly.
And you know what if Hillary Clinton got in,
who fucking blew the bankers in 2008 do you think she would have given a speech
about that?
No.
How many people that they've crushed?
How many people are upside down in a fucking house right now?
No.
Yeah,
I wouldn't have given speech.
Of course she wouldn't have.
Why?
Because she wears a blue bra and fucking Trump was fucking red underwear.
It's fucking stupid.
It's like listening to the Yankees and red sox fans.
I don't know.
I'll be on it,
but this has been this podcast
and I want you guys to know,
I don't feel that I'm any different than you.
I'm walking around right now.
I'm not special.
Okay?
I'm just a person that decided to listen to themselves and I feel that that's
what everybody needs to do and that's not what we're teaching in the educational
system.
Do you not have something that you feel strongly about that you wouldn't maybe
use your platform to discuss?
It's a bunch of Shit I feel strongly about,
but I don't feel like I'm the fucking be all end all and my point,
in my opinion,
I'll end up,
but you have and podcasts that you do twice a flake gate,
the flight gate,
I still fucking passionate about that.
So you have two times a week where you have a guaranteed audience of thousands
upon thousands of people listening to you.
Something here,
I started going Meryl Streep,
Finish Times a fucking week.
I would have no podcasts.
Oh,
I would be podcasting,
but no one would be listening to me finish.
You're being rude.
No fake news.
And you had a chance to talk about like here,
this is the thing that I really feel strongly about.
I feel like people should know.
I want to share.
You don't.
You don't think that you should do that?
No.
Oh,
okay.
Well,
there you go.
How dumb are people?
They don't know what's important.
People know it's important.
People are not dumb.
I've traveled around people.
I don't walk around people like,
Oh my God,
Bill,
talk slower.
I can't get my head around your phone.
Not that.
It's not about like patronizing people.
It's like,
Hey,
here's this thing that came up recently.
This is how I feel about it.
I feel strongly about it and here's why.
Maybe you feel this way too.
Maybe you didn't know about this issue.
Maybe this will maybe help you open up a little bit more about it.
Hey,
that's a great delivery.
Somebody ought to try that sometime.
Are you making fun of me?
No.
Meryl Streep was not delivering it that way,
right?
Well,
he was wagging her fucking finger.
She wasn't wagging.
She was getting a lifetime achievement award and she got up there degree.
What were you in?
Were you in this year?
Nothing.
I like,
why is she going to live?
They've given her every fucking trophy out there.
They're going to give her another one.
Yeah,
she's Meryl Streep.
Listen,
she gets all the awards.
Okay.
Let me,
I'm not saying she shouldn't get the fucking awards,
but why can't you?
But why does it bother you so much that she gets up there and she talks about
what she's passionate about it,
it doesn't bother me so much.
I'm just choosing to make fun of it.
Oh that's all.
Okay.
I find it just cringeworthy when I don't fucking want to listen to,
uh,
you know,
George Kennedy talked to me about the fucking ozone layer,
he just passed away.
You know what I mean?
Charles Bronson copy.
Well the thing is you're not big on award shows period.
I think they're silly.
Right.
And then the speed,
I understand why you have to do it.
I think a lot of people that go to them go to them because you have to,
right.
Cause you have to,
cause what it is is you go in there like,
uh,
you know,
you've got to support the project that you're in.
If is the family gets fucking nominated for something,
I would go yeah,
when I go up there and they fucking stand up there on a deck of day.
Medalia but I mean you've got to do it.
Yeah.
You have to do it cause that's,
that's part of the thing that you signed up for.
It's good.
You know,
if,
if it wins Shit,
the writing staff,
they make more money because then they get to be like,
oh wait,
you know,
I wrote her an Emmy Award winning show or the fucking I an SB,
whatever the fuck he get.
Right.
You have to play the fucking gay.
Yes.
So just go up there.
It say thank you.
I appreciate it.
Take you shiny thing and take a fucking walk like this.
The thing I don't like Trump.
Okay.
I don't like the fucking shit he's doing.
I don't like the people he's picked it,
but I don't need Meryl Streep.
Like I once I sit there like,
oh wait a minute.
He's not a book guy.
Like,
oh thank you Meryl Streep.
Thank you for squeegeeing my fucking third eye.
I know,
I think it's say,
uh,
I think it's one of those things where you're famous too fucking long and you
just start thinking that like everything that you're doing is a little more
important that it is.
You know what I mean?
I have to be honest with India,
like before I got into this business,
no one ever like,
I'm trying to think like a,
at least using that technique,
no one ever influenced me.
Like I like,
um,
there's people that influence me like,
oh,
I want to listen to more of that music for a,
Oh wow,
there's,
there's a part of the world like that.
I'd like to see that.
But like,
you know,
I actually,
I don't see how like somebody make it like a fucking three minutes speech is
going to have more of an impact than someone that you live your day to day with
or your parents [inaudible] you know,
that's like,
that's get that doctor Phil Shit.
Like when they solves problems and like,
while we watched that shit too.
Oh right.
We watch doctor Phil too,
dude living in the truck.
Oh.
And we have watched like judge Judy,
we had a whole like stay at home mom day.
This dude,
this dude was living in a truck with his kid and at night he was in during the
night,
he was in a shelter and they drove around in the truck and it was just,
well,
this kid with his two year old hitting him like Gatorade and sodas and stuff,
and he goes,
you know what?
Sometimes the kid doesn't eat,
but you know,
I always try to make sure you know I,
I feed them when I can make sure he's got plenty of sugar and caffeine.
He said,
yeah,
like that was like,
that was good.
He doesn't get,
he doesn't get them like bottles of water.
He gets it and Gatorade and Coca Cola.
That kid look fine and they never showed us say,
do you mean no,
that was the music yet.
That was the music.
No,
he looked like a feral animal roaming around a little bit.
Cute little kid.
Yeah,
he did it,
but he also looked like a little,
I don't know.
Kids are dirty,
not market.
I might tell you something right now.
That kid's going to be able to figure out shit more than most of these Goddamn
millennials,
you know,
that sat there with their clean fucking fingernails.
Lice,
free heads in their fucking laptops.
All right,
I got to get on with my day here.
Um,
all right,
that's it.
That's the podcast to the movie.
Let's all go to the lobby.
Let's all go to the lobby and the gate.
What we did on the elliptical.
Alright,
go fuck yourselves.
Have a nice weekend.
You can't tell.
Talk to you on Monday.
Eventually
these two.
Okay.
Mama listing book.
I invest in a thing
Monday morning podcast and this is something I have to start off.
I've got to start right out of the gate talking about because someone had,
uh,
someone was bitching at me that they liked my page,
but they couldn't,
they couldn't shut off my podcasts so they could watch the other videos.
Um,
if you are new to my page and you're listening to this podcast and you're
already bored with it,
all you gotta do is just scroll down.
It's right on the right hand side.
And it's a little XC.
Just click on it.
You'll burn half a calorie donuts and then you can do whatever else you want to
do on the site.
All right.
Okay.
Bruce,
can you figure that out?
Um,
anyways,
what's going on?
How are you?
How was your week?
Do you have a nice week everybody?
I actually had a great fucking week.
I'll show you.
When people do that,
they ask you about something and they don't really give a fuck.
They just setting it up so they can talk about it.
It's like,
I knew I had an awesome week.
So rather than just coming out and being braggadocious,
if that's even a fucking word,
and just saying,
I had an awesome week,
I had to actually act like I was a considerate human being and remotely gave a
fuck about what your week was like.
I had an awesome week.
This is what I want to get to.
You don't want the end.
People do that.
And then you start to talk about your weekend and like they start doing that.
Nod that,
wrap it up.
That really hyper quick fucking chip Monck nod like Eh,
maybe a little circular motion with the left hand light.
Let's get to the point so I can get on and just download all my shit on the your
spirit.
All right.
Wow.
What an intro that's not going to make you want to listen to this.
Anyways,
this is basically my awesome week.
I went to the Improv in Tampa,
Florida.
I have to say that just in case there's a city in Ohio also named Tampa cause I
know they have Miami,
Ohio.
Just fucking hilarious.
It's got them frozen state.
I live in West Palm Beach,
Florida.
No,
Ohio outside of Dayton.
Um,
yeah,
so I was,
I cannot begin to tell you guys how much dread I was looking at my first two
gigs of this year,
Tampa,
Florida and Houston,
Texas.
Both cities I was looking at with dread.
I'm still looking at Houston with dread.
Why you ask,
is it because you don't like Tampa?
Bill did is you got something against the oil makers in Houston now it's because
the last time I went to both those towns combined,
I think 30 people came up to came out to see me,
you know,
and I'm like,
I'm not going to lie to you guys.
I'm an older fellow at this point.
And,
uh,
going on the road can be hard sometimes and if you don't believe me,
just talk to that Filipino who's singing for journey.
He's already bitching fucking little pussy.
You believe that guy fucking guy's singing karaoke in a third world country and
now he's playing the Goddamn fucking La Forum and he's complaining about how
lonely the road is because he's been out there for fucking six weeks.
Jesus Christ.
You know,
I can't tell if that guy is just a whiny little con or fee or fees of fucking
maybe does,
knows who he is and he can actually step outside of this and you don't do it.
I really just wanted to fucking sing karaoke and uh,
you know,
singing with you guys was awesome and I'm over it cause I know it really makes
me happy.
My friends and my family and making little Bok Choy as I squat and my hut or
whatever the fuck it is that they do over there at typical American.
I don't know where you from.
You know,
I think you're squatting in a hut eaten Bok Choy.
I didn't even know about Joe is,
and I've had it,
I think it's Korean.
Is that Kimchi?
Um,
boy have a fuck that guy.
You know what I mean?
Why can't you just be honest and just be like,
you know what?
Um,
I thought I liked journeys music when I was singing it once every other Tuesday
and um,
King Fung Woo's bar and grill in fucking the Philippines,
but uh,
you know,
singing it,
every night's kind of fucking boring.
And I'm out here with a bunch of fucking geezers.
We're trying to recapture some other shit.
And one of them,
the guy who the keyboards is still wearing his tight pants and it's just
something I don't like seeing,
but I don't have enough say in the band being as I'm a fucking contest winner.
Jesus Christ.
Can you imagine the awkwardness on the road?
Like this fucking guy that could go,
you know,
they actually went through all the bullshit that band.
Okay.
They ate fucking spaghetti every God damn week,
whatever the fuck they did.
They lived in a van and they fuck in down by the river and they fucking made it.
You know,
they made it and then they got no big fight with Steve Perry because he thought
he could go on his own making oh,
Sherry and some other forgettable sappy shit and uh,
you know,
lawsuits,
all that behind the music shit.
And now they're back on tour again and they just fucking plucked this guy,
you know,
up out of a tsunami and now he's playing,
look,
I just don't understand how,
how do you fucking bond?
You know what I mean?
That'd be like me.
Last time I played quarterback I think was just fucking some pickup game in
eighth grade and all of a sudden I'm fucking,
you know,
I show up in week,
week 15
for the ravens that don't know.
You made the point.
Why don't you get back to you Greg Week?
Hey,
why don't I own up to the fact that I told you guys last week that my,
the Carolina Panthers were my dark horse and I believe that Jake the loan and
what happens,
I jinxed him.
You heard of the sports illustrated jinx is a new genx in town and you fucking
listening to it.
So my apologies to everybody in Carolina.
Um,
in my mind I'm going to Carolina.
All right,
let me get back to my awesome weeks 20 ways.
Yeah.
Last time I went to Tampa,
nobody fucking showed up.
And uh,
and it was really disheartening because I think at that point my HBO special was
out and that type of thing and that's when it really just hit me how fucking
hard this businesses.
And I was really like,
wow,
man,
what the fuck do I have to do?
So I went to Tampa and what happened?
I showed up and a bunch of fucking people showed up and they were great crowds
and I got like,
you know,
a couple,
two or three partial standing ovations.
I was killing it.
I was having a great time after my nuts.
Nice month of rest and relaxation from a bunch of finance bitches.
Came out to the club baby.
Um,
no,
a lot of good looking broads down there and uh,
and I'd probably drink too much fucking to what a three nights
was a good time.
We don't like that Kyle had show if anybody from that show is listening,
um,
tell him I said thank you.
So fucking great show.
I'm going to list,
this is how cool this is.
How great the whole week was.
I went in to the cow head show right off the bat.
That guy's totally cool right off the bat.
He knows how to give a great interview.
I don't have to do material.
We just vibing,
everything's flowing.
And then all of a sudden,
out of nowhere,
a guide,
one of my buddies from high school,
when I had season tickets to the patriots in 1989 when they sucked and we used
to all pile in the back of his landscaping truck with that half keg of fucking
beer and a bag of chips that he fucking calls up,
find out he's living down there.
Next thing you know where on the radio together talking about Shit we did 20
years ago,
and if that wasn't cool enough,
they had an electronic drum kit there and they came out of the radio break
playing the immigrant song and I was on the drums playing fighters with fucking
heaven,
this total geek moment.
And then I went down to the club and it was fucking,
you know,
I'm not going to say it's packed,
but I got into the upper deck,
you know,
just picture a uh,
just picture and Atlanta Braves game when they finally make it to the fucking,
the,
the NLCS.
That's how full the club,
it's about three quarters full.
Fuck you guys.
That was all happy with that.
I thought that was,
I mean nobody down there.
So I want to thank everybody down there.
So Houston you got to come through for me.
Okay.
Want to go up and I play that Improv that's underneath that overpass and that
strip mall where evidently there's a lot of violence.
Who the fuck did the research on that one
anyways?
I also like when you walk into that one,
how it looks like scar faces,
lobby.
Just the fucking,
I don't fucking know.
Anyways,
why am I shitting on a club then I'm going to,
no,
it's a great time.
It's a great part of town.
And uh,
all I know is I got to,
I finally got my new wow.
It's together and I'm really happy and it's,
it's really,
it's,
it's a,
if things are going good,
so just fucking come out all right.
For the love of God.
But either way,
even if it sucks,
I'm going to south pole guitars so I'll still have a good time and I'm going to
go skating at your fucking mall cause I'm,
let's say,
oh right.
So let's get into the podcast here.
So I have hyped what I have coming up.
I'm going to be at the Improv in Houston and a,
these are the dates.
Uh,
22nd 23rd and 24th go to Improv to Dotcom for all information.
And I'll be selling my brand new DVD.
I'll be standing there like a fucking jackass in the end cause I have no pride.
Um,
actually I decided something,
um,
that,
you know,
cause there's a lot of guys are like,
once they get past a certain level they don't want to stand there selling
merchandise at the end of this show.
Um,
cause you feel like an idiot sometimes.
And um,
I got to admit I don't,
I actually like kind of meeting people left shows lungs are not drunk morons
slapping me too hard in the back and spitting on me inadvertently.
I don't mind that shit,
but this is something that I'm not doing anymore or at least I want to say I'm
not going to,
um,
who's kidding,
who I'm going to do it because there's nothing worse than bringing DVDs home and
your luggage,
you fucking bag weighs like 80 pounds.
But like I hate when I work at club where I have two shows and however the crowd
walks in,
there's not enough room to have the next crowd stand there and have the other
crowd walk out.
So they send the first crowd out the side door and if you want to sell your
merge,
you're literally standing outside the club.
And I cannot begin to tell you how much of a fucking moron
I feed in people's eyes too.
When they see me,
like I was doing,
like I was standing outside the Improv and not Tampa.
And they have like,
it's one of those,
you know,
as the,
as the guy like a sports bought a movie theater,
it's all like this one little,
they can say an outdoor mall.
And I'm literally standing there and people are going,
excuse me,
excuse me.
People who don't give a fuck about the shell,
who have no idea who I am and an audience members who like give a shit,
who I am really see where I am in this business in that moment is some plumber
just goes,
hey,
uh,
a pasty.
When did you get the fuck out of the way?
So I can go see a,
well,
you know,
oh my God,
what Benjamin Buttons.
This is going to be at disjointed podcast.
I don't give a fuck.
Right?
I'm on some new diet.
My fucking just had eight egg whites.
I'm never doing that again man.
It's just fucking brutal.
I saw that movie Benjamin Buttons.
Bill,
can you stick with the subject?
Yes,
that's what I'm saying.
I don't want to fucking stand outside of club and do that shit anymore.
Okay.
I'll stand in the club,
but there's a table,
you know,
I would even make the change.
I don't give a shit,
but I think I'm going to draw the line and I'm not going to stand outside of
venue dealing with the elements and people on their way to a fucking Applebee's.
As I tried to hock my merchandise because,
uh,
I've,
I've gotta admit,
I felt,
uh,
felt pretty,
pretty pathetic,
pretty fucking pathetic.
So,
um,
anyways,
let's get on.
Let's get on with the podcast here and remind me to talk about led Zeppelin
later.
I don't know how you're going to do that,
so I might as well talk about it now.
I'm pretty devastated because I fucking love that group.
And I had heard rumors and I kind of knew they had a couple of blues songs that
they reworked in air quotes and they didn't quite give people credit for it and
uh,
evidently it goes way beyond that.
And uh,
there's some stuff on youtube.
I'm always looking at led Zepplin shit cause I'm a huge John Bonham fan and
somehow I stumbled across this thing cause I guess the Youtube Guy was just on
Howard Stern.
So there was a lot of shit on them about them stealing material.
And uh,
all I can say is wow,
it went beyond a couple of songs.
It went into,
I mean every song but two songs and their first album,
half the songs on their second album,
they're even trying to say that they ripped off the intro to stairway to heaven.
They had like an opening act on tour with them.
I just,
I dunno,
I don't know how to process it.
And not only that,
I just brought my about my nephew,
the fucking box set,
the entire digitally remaster,
remaster box set of led Zepplin for Christmas.
You know,
thinking I'm the cool uncle and I just gave him a,
uh,
a box of stolen shit.
Just fucking brutal checkout that Jeff Beck album truth.
I just downloaded it.
How many more times?
He literally takes a section straight up from the guy,
but you know,
I think that's on those other guys.
They should should've just fun.
You know,
you know what it is.
You can't do anything.
It's nothing you can do about it.
They fucking steel and they get credit and they get taken into the hall of fame
is fucking brutal.
All right.
That was a bummer.
Did I just say a bummer?
They actually kind of worked because I was talking about music from the 60.
[inaudible] that was a bummer man.
What a drag.
Um,
all right.
Anyway,
so last week I got up on my soapbox a little bit or my Ottoman,
if you want to get technical.
And
I was talking about last week how I'm sick of going into these places of
business and with this new technology,
they're firing fellow Americans and they're making me do the,
the fired employee's job.
And to me that is not progress.
All right?
That is,
uh,
adding another person out there who's going to be competing for me for a job
while I do their fucking job for free.
So I asked people what they thought about that shit.
You know what I'm talking specifically about going into a grocery store and they
want me to check myself out.
Okay.
As if I'm somehow going to do it faster than a cashier.
That seems to be the illusion here that that makes it faster.
You know what I mean?
Somebody who actually works there and does it 9,000 times a day so they can only
have to look at the fucking keyboard.
Goddamn Stevie wonder,
fucking blowing through it,
you know,
and somehow I'm going to be quicker than that,
you know?
So anyways,
I asked people what they thought about it and uh,
I got an interesting,
I got to,
you know,
basically I took two of them that kind of summed up everybody's shit and then I
switched up some of the guitar parts and I called it stairway to heaven.
No,
wait a minute.
All right.
Um,
somebody said,
I agree with you.
New Technologies often make certain jobs obsolete,
but they also create new ones.
And this case,
I don't think there are enough low level jobs out there to start getting rid of
cashiers.
Um,
yeah,
and I definitely agree with you.
I,
I don't feel like
they're making you,
you're walking into the grocery stores,
the customer,
they're making you be a cashier for free and everyone's sitting there going out.
It's quicker.
This is what this guy said.
This guy is saying let's guys find to go bill.
As far as the self checkout line and grocery store,
I can't agree with your take on the situation.
Any place I have seen with self checkout lines still have regular lines as well.
Can you believe that point?
Any place I've seen with self checkout lines still have the regular lines as
well.
Obviously they're just not overnight going to get rid of everybody.
They're teaching you how to be a cashier for free and once we all get it down,
eventually they're going to get rid of everybody the same way.
They don't want it with like those tolls,
those easy fast things that you know never.
There was only one easy pass line.
Now it's down.
There's only one toll booth line and sometimes you get off the exit.
There is no toll booth.
You just better have the fucking right amount of change,
you know?
I guess that does make it easier,
but also let them know where the fuck you are.
Which annoys the shit on me,
but I wasn't bitching about that.
It would be only reason why 10 out of 10 lines are not automated is because it's
a new technology and that's why they have the douche standing there teaching you
how to fucking use.
They teaching you how to be a cashier so they can fire other cashiers and then
they don't have to pay cashiers and you as the customer who used to just come up
with your food to stand there and rubbed your fucking balls looking around you.
Don't you understand the arrogance of that.
Hey,
why don't you come into my store,
pick out what you want.
You figure out what the fuck you all me pay me,
stick you stick it in the bag and then get the fuck out of my store.
You'll find a problem with that.
Anyways,
this guy continues to say,
I don't think anyone is losing any jobs or that grocery stores are going to turn
into self serving only venues.
I'm sorry,
but I'm going to stand in line.
I'm not going to stand in line behind the soccer mom who's buying enough
groceries to last the entire winter.
Meanwhile,
all I got is a box of cereal,
cereal,
and milk,
and now I have to tell myself I'm doing a good thing for the workforce by Resu
refusing to serve myself and the self checkout line.
Not In this lifetime.
My fine feathered friend,
he really thought he made a great point there.
What do you know what?
I think you're a retard when you think about that.
Who stands in line in front of behind somebody who's got enough fucking
groceries for the winter when all you have is a box of cereal and milk?
Have you ever heard of the express checkout eight items or less heavy?
You never noticed that.
You know what?
That,
that uh,
that this fucking pissed,
that whole thing just pissed me off.
You know what?
Get,
it's great to get stand in line and go do a job you didn't have to do before and
do it for free and put somebody else out of work and tell yourself that it's
fucking quicker.
The same way they're doing that on TV where they got that commercial and they
try to mind fuck you into thinking that using your ATM card is quicker than
using cash.
You know,
come on man,
you should fucking head.
You know what?
They're doing this phase and out cash,
so now there's no more under the table bullshit out there and you're going to
get taxed even fucking more and they'll know where you are at all fucking times.
That's what they're doing.
Alright?
Debit cards are not quicker than cash,
and I love the commercial that they have.
I don't know if this is still running it,
but they literally used homophobia to try to convince you.
You know,
they,
they put into that part of your brain,
Hey,
I'm not sucking Dick.
I'm going to use a fucking debit card.
They basically had this commercial,
they had a bunch of people buying a Steelers jerseys.
I remember they're all buying football jerseys and they're going through the
line and everybody's using a debit card and they're playing that bugs bunny
music.
Dunt dunt Duh,
Duh,
and everything's going great and it's,
and people are swiping at once and they just grabbing the bag and the whole
transaction takes literally two seconds.
Okay.
Which has not been my experience ever.
The Guy fucking tried to put the password in,
it doesn't fucking work.
They swipe it three times and the cashier finally spins the thing around,
tries to do it themselves.
It's a big fucking pain in the ass.
So anyways,
after all these guys cruise through,
then this,
you know,
buying football jerseys,
this fucking guy comes up to buy tennis balls with a pink sweater tied around
his neck and he's piece paying cash.
And the second he takes out the cash,
you know that,
that music just comes to a dead halt and everybody's staring at them.
You get it,
you know,
football men,
tennis,
pink sweater,
Fag,
I just fucking unreal.
You know,
fuck this shit.
I'm just gonna go live in the fucking mountains.
I'm tired of trying to convince people.
I had this stupid girl in the front row as explaining the whole fucking thing to
her.
And she's like,
still told me that the thing that she was going to use the automated checkout at
the cashier at the,
at the grocery store,
because I go,
why?
She goes,
because it's
how,
how has it,
how has it quicker,
you know,
you could teach me how to change a fucking tire.
I'm not going to do a quick and then I'm fucking mechanic or change my oil or
what I don't fucking whatever,
whatever,
whatever.
Standing those fucking lines.
You've fucking drones.
Oh see all childless again,
when people have a different opinion,
this is why I can't sustain a relationship.
Okay,
let's get,
let's get to the,
you know,
it really is,
I'm just fucking annoyed that I found out that one of the groups that I loved
has stolen all this God damn music.
I want to do it.
It just,
you know,
you know what's funny about it lets up on as they always had that,
that cheesy shit where they would just like trying to say that they all sold
their soul to the devil.
Everybody sold their soul to the devil except for John Paul Jones.
And that's why all about that horrific shit happened.
Like John Bonham died.
Robert Plant got in a car accident and this kid died mysteriously and uh,
Jimmy Page,
I dunno,
he fucking,
his eyes got all squinty.
I Dunno.
What the fuck,
what happened?
Jimmy page?
He didn't lose a finger.
That was a guy from black sabbath.
Bam.
Did Jimmy page.
He had a castle.
I Dunno some,
I'm going to Jimmy page,
some Adam bad to everybody.
But you know what the reason it wasn't that they sold the soul,
it was Karma for steel and all those fucking songs
you've been inducted into the hall of fame.
All right.
Whatever.
Okay.
Anyways,
you know what?
I should have been more mature about that.
Some people don't fucking agree with me on those.
Uh,
those automated lines.
I just,
I know I can me,
it's clear as fucking day.
It's clear as fucking day,
you know,
I'm not a hundred percent against you.
Like when I go to the airport,
sometimes that automated shit is quicker.
Like when you go to check yourself in for a flight,
that's definitely,
definitely fucking quicker.
But when I get on the plane and they start telling me I need to fold up my
blanket to help expedite the cleaning of the cabin,
go fuck yourself.
All right?
That's for the cleaning crew.
I'm sorry they fired the cleaning crew.
I'm not doing that fucking job.
I did my job.
I got on the plane.
I said a prayer on takeoff and landing that we wouldn't crash.
I didn't try to open the emergency door or charged the cockpit.
I'm done.
You know,
I'm not taking out a fucking limp.
Russian,
a crumb bar and cleaning up my fucking area.
Go Fuck Yourself.
I don't work for the airline.
And we go,
Hey,
and I'm getting a new laptop this week,
so this is the last time you're going to hear that fucking annoying clicking
sound,
trying to do it smoother.
All right,
let's get to the podcast questions for the weekend.
I got to tell you guys,
this is going to be a short podcast this week because,
uh,
I have a ton of shit to do.
I'm like,
can I just be nicer?
Um,
I appreciate you guys all listening to my podcast.
Like,
I have to go back into there,
the 700 club guy,
you know,
put your hands on your lap top screen.
Let's say praying for cheese.
I'm no,
I appreciate all you guys listening and all that type of stuff and uh,
we're gonna be blown through it.
Why can't you have a sensitive moment,
Phil?
Why can't you open up?
Okay.
Take a deep breath.
Let it out.
I appreciate the fact that all you guys listen to my podcasts,
but uh,
I have a lot of um,
things that I have to get done to.
I can't fucking do it.
I got a lot of shit to do.
All right,
question number one.
Uh,
Bill,
you often talk on the cast of how people shouldn't work.
Certain jobs that helped the man
fucked and fucked the common folk.
One of my jobs I currently work cause I'm broke is essentially telemarketing and
I go home from it feeling dirty,
but who's fault is it really mine or the dopes?
I'm fucking and where exactly do draw the line of what jobs to not work
according to your personal standards.
All right.
A telemarketing.
I mean,
that's not making me do a job.
So I mean,
as annoying as it is,
you can,
you can sign yourself up for that.
Don't call list on the Internet if you guys want to look that up.
I did that and nobody ever fucking calls me.
And uh,
um,
but I mean,
I don't know what you'd tell a marketing.
You say you go home feeling dirty.
I'd have to know what it is that you do because you're like,
I feel really guilty,
but who's fault is it?
Mine or the dopes?
I'm fucking so obviously,
whatever you're selling them is bullshit and you know,
it's bullshit,
but you're telling them that it's,
it's great shit.
So,
uh,
who's fault is that?
Ah,
that's yours.
I'm going to say that's yours.
You know,
you know,
dude,
you know what's yours?
You go home feeling dirty.
You're obviously doing some shit you don't want to do.
But I understand any port in a storm,
I don't know if he's selling people sham wows like morons like me and I buy it a
fucking things.
You know,
you're not really hurt.
I don't know what the fuck I'd have to know what you're selling.
You know,
if it's selling those fucking mortgages that screwed over this economy,
then you should feel dirty.
But,
uh,
I dunno,
I don't fucking know.
I'm trying to think,
you know,
something I used to tell the market so I can't judge you.
I refuse to sell newspaper subscriptions over the phone and you know,
when you're just doing that sort of cold calling,
the only weapon you have is the lie your ass off.
And the only way I got through it was trying to make the guy next to me laugh.
I used to go by Bill Macdonald and uh,
the other guy,
what the fuck did he get?
One of the guys I worked with actually went by the name Keith Crowder,
who was the name of one of the guys who actually played on the Boston Bruins and
we were in Boston.
He used to call people up,
hey,
how you doing?
This is Keith crowd or calm from the Boston globe.
And people would just,
every once in a while some of you like,
oh yeah,
Keith Crowder.
He'd be like,
Oh yeah,
you gotta be,
Oh,
you played for the Bruins and [inaudible] got it's my cousin.
Or he would just say that.
Oh yeah,
I get that all the time.
You know what I mean?
Like if your name was actually Barry Manilow or some shit,
um,
I don't know,
Dude.
I'm not trying to make you feel guilty.
I would just try to get out of that fucking job.
But dude,
if he can't get out of that job,
I mean,
what do you,
what are you gonna do?
And all depends on what you're doing,
dude.
If his stealing from old ladies and taking that their life savings and uh,
you know,
I had a buddy of mine,
he was doing something like that and he ended up in jail.
See Better Watch out whatever you're doing.
Um,
you know what I'm really feeling like I'm fucking getting preachy and righteous
here.
Um,
and I don't know shit.
Just know that I don't lead,
you know,
even all that shit I just said about led Zeppelin.
Actually,
you know what,
that wasn't just youtube shit I watched on Youtube and this kid had the music to
back it up.
So,
but anything else is a,
that comes in our mouse mostly is bullshit.
All right,
question number two.
Uh,
Bill,
is there any way to get links to the individual podcast?
I try to subscribe,
but I don't think it worked.
I'm not really as retarded as a computer makes me look.
I could not identify with you more.
That's exactly what happens to me every time I tried to watch or listen to
anything on the,
on the computer and I have no idea.
I don't know how to help you.
I really don't.
Um,
I'm like,
I don't know.
what the fuck is that?
That that holiday and commercial,
you know?
No,
I don't know.
I don't know computers,
but I stayed at a Holiday Inn last night and Holiday Inn express or whatever the
fuck it is.
That's how I am.
You know,
I'm on the computer.
I know how to put up a podcast,
but I don't know how to do any of that other stuff.
So if anybody's listening has this information and what's the email or two to
me,
I'll read it next week and I'll pass it off as my own.
Just like Jimmy page.
Skinny icon.
All right.
Question number three.
You must get a ton of podcasts,
questions and overrated,
underrated stuff.
How do you decide which ones to use in your podcasts?
Um,
I basically any anytime somebody,
if it's a repeat question,
um,
like I,
I try to ignore those,
but once every six months I will answer the question,
how did you get involved in stand up?
But,
um,
and then just,
yeah,
they're good questions.
I feel like I can go off on them and they have funny then that's basically how I
do it.
But if it's a slow week,
I'll read every God damn one of them,
cause I don't get a ton of them.
I get like a dozen or so,
so a,
so if you have a question,
are you thinking like,
Oh man,
he's not even going to read it.
[inaudible] chances are I will read it.
You got an 80% chance.
How about that?
80% chance.
And that's based on not even mathematically studying it on any level.
All right,
question number four,
Bill.
Have you ever seen two guys start comparing scars?
Are these two guys just a bunch of tools or what?
Usually by the end,
one or the other has pulled up his shirt and pulled down his pants.
What?
A bunch of fags.
I got to admit,
I've never seen that.
Do you hang out in a pirate bar?
I have no idea.
That would be weird.
I,
yeah,
that's kind of awkward.
Uh,
reminds me of a,
that,
that scene in jaws where they just sit around a,
yeah,
this right here.
Fucking
electric eels Zap me.
Oh yeah,
this a sting ray stuck me in the nuts,
whatever.
Now I've never seen that,
but I'm,
I,
the way the picture you painted,
I'd have to agree with your assessment.
You've got to say something like,
why don't you two fucking hacked up pussies?
Pull up your pants please.
For the love of God.
Anyways,
you know,
I resent seeing,
I resent seeing a middle aged man who has a smooth chest and that because they
shaved it.
Just the hair never came in and they got those fucking five daddy long legs
hanging off a one nipple and they don't work out and it's just all just,
it looks like a,
it looks like a melted snow man.
Ah,
that's why I don't,
I'm not a Jew.
I'm not a member of gym.
All right,
Bill,
if you and Jim Norton Never Comparative Appendix Scars.
Uh,
no,
no I haven't.
No,
I,
this is a whole new fucking world that I don't want to get involved in.
This is some sort of,
do they have scar porn?
This is really making me uncomfortable.
Uh,
Bill,
besides your appendix scar,
what is your best scar and how did it happen?
All right,
they can answer this one.
I have one right above my left eyebrow that you can only see when if I'm
imitating the rock.
And how I got it was my older brother threw me off the porch headfirst and I
landed like a lawn dart into a flagstone.
This is basically,
it's basically the story.
We had a,
you have a,
you know those,
those,
those porch swings that they have back in the day where uh,
if you,
if you came,
if you recording back in the day you'd come and they wouldn't let you go
anywhere.
So you'd sit out on a,
on a spring and it's on a swing.
It's like basically a love seat,
but it's a swing and you sit out there and sing like light or rose or something.
Lot rose.
I'm home again.
Roseann barbershop quartet would show up like in the music man.
Yeah,
we had one of us.
So somehow my brother pissed me off and he was swinging like a fucking maniac on
that thing.
So I grabbed,
I think it was a rake.
I Dunno what,
that it's not important what the business end of it was because it's really,
the story is about the handle of whatever I grabbed.
So it's a brome,
it's a rake.
I don't know what the fuck it was.
And as when he got up to the top,
I stood underneath him like I was in 300 you know,
and I just held that stick up and I fucking caught him right in his stomach.
And I held him for probably like half a second.
And then I dropped the broom handle,
whatever.
And I turned around and I went to run off of the porch and he had the momentum
of the swing coming down.
So he immediately was like right behind me.
Like you have a watch the roadrunner and the coyote.
When the coyote chases the road runner,
Rolando goes flying by him and he's at a dead stop and somehow he catches all
the way up to them except for the last three feet.
That's what the fuck my brother did.
But he had the aid of a swing.
So I'm right at the top step of the porch and he just sort of pushed me in the
middle of my back.
Look Claude Lemieux action.
Right?
And that's when I just went fucking airborne.
And uh,
I don't know if I ever told you this guy is the size of my huge head right now.
I had this head when I was,
it was the same size when I was born,
so I was probably 11 years old.
So let's,
you know,
for the sake of the story,
I'm fucking top heavy,
right?
So I immediately start going down like a fucking javelin and it happened so
fast,
I couldn't get my hands out.
He,
if I could,
I would've broke both my wrists trying to stop terminal velocity of my skull and
I just fucking went headfirst into this flagstone and a had a nice gash.
Actually took out a little chunk of my skull,
a little sliver of it,
of my Frankenstein brow.
And,
uh,
I just remember getting up and I went back up to the top of the porch and I was
leaning over the banister cause I didn't want to start bleeding in the house
cause I knew my dad was going to freak out cause he already had to stitch me up.
My Dad's a dentist,
so,
uh,
it's kind of cool.
Anytime you got stitches,
you didn't have to go to the hospital.
He just fucking,
it was like go like in between periods.
They just sew you up on the bench.
He just,
I can't do it right there and we,
you know,
it's funny,
we always ended up having to get stitches on his day off,
pull past,
it used to work like three weeks in a row,
we get one day off and then one of us would fall out of a tree or accidentally
in air quotes,
throw a fucking rockets.
And you know,
I did that one.
And uh,
we always use the same excuse,
I was running through the woods and I tripped and he'd be like,
oh Christ's sake,
I don't need this shit
any fucking either.
Yeah,
he just lays down on the sofa.
You don't numb us up.
And he starts stitching us up and we'd be going out and he'd be like,
come on,
stop it.
Stop it.
That doesn't hurt that bad.
And uh,
yeah,
then you'd have a fucking scarf.
There you go.
That's my,
uh,
do I have any other ones?
I got bit in the face by my own dog.
That was a good one.
We had this little West Highland terrier and uh,
we just kept fucking with them.
Um,
I don't know why.
I can't even remember why at this point is so fucking long ago.
We basically turned them into an attack dog.
We started off just rough housing with them and then he would bite.
It's a little too hard.
And then we moved onto a garden glove and we started playing will be called the
glove game and we just keep pushing them in the face and then he figured out how
to bite.
So then we moved on to,
I think like hockey sticks and we just,
you know,
wasn't hit them really hard.
We just sorta like actually,
you know,
had trying to dig out the puck in the corner.
We kind of do that shit and he'd start biting at it.
And I remember when he,
when he would bite down on it and he finally learned to start shaking it going
like,
oh,
I'm doing that shit.
We thought it was the funniest shit ever,
you know?
And we were all like,
ages two to 10,
you know,
this is back in the day too,
when,
you know,
there was no Oprah Winfrey,
so people didn't know that you shouldn't leave fucking five kids under the age
of 10 at home with a dog and electricity,
you know?
And uh,
so yeah.
So we just turned this talking to a fucking attack though.
How can we really taught him how to bite?
And we all thought it was hilarious until he started doing it to us.
And,
uh,
so one day my brother is sitting on the couch and he's eating a sandwich and my
dog sitting there sitting up begging,
you know,
little shit,
little terrier.
So I start crawling up next to him just going,
hey,
I'm going to get to food.
I'm going to get the food.
He said,
nick on er,
er,
he keeps looking over at me and I just kept creeping up going,
I'm going to get the food.
And then he started doing like that half a fucking smile.
Show me his fangs and what?
Laughing.
That's always do just drive him fucking the same way we do it in my little
brother just piss him off.
We just fun to watch somebody lose their shit.
And uh,
the dog was no exception.
And then I don't know what happened.
I took it too far and he just lunged over to bite me.
And I was,
my face was at his face,
his level,
and he just grabbed me on the same side,
same side.
When my brother threw me off the porch,
he fucking sunk in just below my eye into my cheek.
And then one of his lower canines was actually inside my mouth and he had my
entire fucking left cheek and he went like that.
And he knew we fucked up too because he's getting me on the leg and he didn't
give a fuck.
Boy when he did that,
when he was like,
oh shit,
that's easily a 10 minute misconduct if not in fucking game suspension.
Um,
yeah.
And that was a,
it was a,
that was a rough walk into the bathroom.
I remember that.
I get hurt.
It kind of felt like a,
I was just like a,
I was worried I was going to be deformed.
So that was the thing.
Like I was going to look in the mirror,
I was like,
oh my God,
am I going to look like a,
like someone who just got bitten and faced by a fucking terrier and somehow I
did.
He kinda,
they were like puncture wounds.
I still see him and I'm looking in the mirror right now.
It kind of faded away,
but that the one on my upper lip,
I don't fucking know.
But then I had to go to my dad's office and he was already working on other
people.
So he was pissed and it was also embarrassing.
The next day when I went to school,
you know,
face is all bruised up and I had stitches were having,
he faced and I was like,
God,
I got bit by a dog who's dog?
Oh my dog.
And like,
did you get rid of it now?
Why not?
Because my family is fucked in the head.
What do you think?
You know,
dogs aren't supposed to do with that shit.
They supposed to,
you know,
chase frisbees and be skipping along with you as you walked back from catching
catfish.
Right.
And that's supposed to bite you in the fucking face,
but you know,
I deserve to.
So there you go.
There's my scar stories for the week.
Um,
I didn't get a chance to get to underrated overrated this week.
I'll just add to them next week we'll have a giant,
we'll have a bonus section of underrated overrated because there was some really
good ones this week.
And,
uh,
and that is it.
Um,
what do I got?
What?
I got a hyper real quick.
Oh,
please.
Uh,
please come see me at the Improv in Houston,
Texas.
Go to Improv,
the number two.com or you can click on the link.
Went on my homepage and Boston.
I am a big trip back to Boston in February 6th and I'm not trying to be a
cheeseball here,
but tickets are fucking,
they're selling like hotcakes
in such a ridiculous fucking statement that's selling like hotcakes really.
Who came up with that?
You know,
you know what I'm having and I'm every going to try to explore that comedically.
Cause that is just such a hacky,
like want to be Jerry Seinfeld fucking bit,
you know,
someone like hardcore drugs or what's the deal with Glenn?
Was there a period?
And
um,
I like how I said it wasn't going to do that and then I just did it.
What do you think about that?
You know,
so right now you guys should just be shutting up the podcast because I've
obviously established the fact that,
that I'm not a man of my word.
You know,
I worked with this comedian Ryan Dalton this weekend and I was going to do
something.
I really fucked it up.
I was meaning to try to get some girl to show her tits at the end of the show.
And we were trying to come up with a way to do it,
you know,
I was going to do it in a silly way.
Like,
come on man economy's bad,
you know,
just,
just do it for America.
Just make it silly.
You know,
there'd be one girl would be willing to do it.
And then we try and thinking about like reverse psychology,
like a,
you know,
I've had to,
keep it going for Ryan.
Any of these need a great comedian,
I'll tell you.
But he's really bashful off stage.
And the other night this girl was showing her tits and he,
he just turned off beat red is one of the funniest,
you know,
try to fucking make it look like he's not a little fucking creep,
you have,
the reality was was I wanted to see some titties and I was using him as an
excuse
and I kind of forgot to do that.
You know,
I was really upset with myself because if I,
I,
if I miss a joke,
I forget to do a joke.
I don't give a fuck of a how do the joke next show.
But you know,
when you miss out on titties,
you know that one sticks with you.
All right?
That's it.
That's the podcast for this week.
Thank you for listening.
As always.
Uh,
everybody have a great week and a wow.
My Christmas,
he's fucking dead.
This thing is fucking dead.
Cold,
dry and brittle.
This thing is,
sorry,
buddy.
Christmas is over.
All right.
Yeah,
the
long
time.
About two weeks.
Same
time.
It's food.
[inaudible].